what I'm about to show you is not you
know I've showed you if you remember our
rational functions and I said you've let
your rational function fare factorize
you get asymptotes your intercepts then
you do share your regions and you'll be
fine
right the set of four steps it does you
every single time there's not really at
least you haven't got one yet a set of
all these other steps that will help me
work this thing out and it's like I do
this every single time the reason why is
because and this is why I'm showing it
to you this is a special case special
cases are deliberately designed to help
you see sometimes you can't just machine
out the steps in and out pops your
answer okay so I'm gonna take a couple
of approaches on this for starters let's
just get the general shape of this thing
okay now if you compare these guys okay
just compare these guys right you can
get some pretty easy patterns out of it
right like okay let's let's just do X
that's that's fine okay linear function
when you go to x squared you're getting
this 9 now when you go to X cubed
you're getting something that's steeper
and it has this odd symmetry about it
okay and then when you come to here you
lose a half you agree with that okay now
just for a second I'm just trying to get
a sense of the shape right just have a
look at your first quadrant for a minute
okay it goes steepest steep not really
steep it's a straight line and then this
is shallow right so I am guessing like
this is X to power 2/3 where does this
fit in the scheme
like shallowly one two three four
is it not between three and four two
thirds is between a half and one right
okay so it's somewhere in here it's
gonna resemble one of these yeah let's
have a go okay let's have a go at this
right now
he's my I'm just trying to use my
intuition first right I'm expecting I'm
guessing right it's like good up the
scale I'm getting steeper and steeper
and steeper right does that make sense
so I'm expecting something as steep as
this but not as steep as that yep
there's my first tool my second tool is
I can differentiate this thing right
it's not much difference yeah dy on DX
what happens to the two-thirds comes out
the front right and then you reduce the
power by one okay so this is a negative
power so it's gonna go on the
denominator so I'm getting this you
happy with that okay now what's this
thing look like what does it look like
okay so for starters for starters I do
have and an asymptote at x equals zero
right I can't go but I can't go
everywhere else right I can go
everywhere else if I have a really
really small number here okay like close
to zero I can't get to zero if I get
close to zero right if this is a very
small number then what will a cube root
of a very very small number then will
also be smaller right be also small and
so three times a really really small
number
it'll be a very very small number you
follow me so uh is there I've got the
small number on the denominator a small
number on the denominator so what does
that mean about the whole number it's
huge right it's doing this kind of thing
yeah you know that
okay so now what happens as this
increases as a skyrockets okay put in a
million there if you like right yeah
million because in fact a million is a
cute number right QB number the cube
root of a million it's got six zeros
right it's it's a hundred yeah so this
is gonna be a hundred sorry
yeah the cube root of it yeah all right
so this is going to become very very
large right you want to get there
quickly cuz the cube root
but it will get there so if I have a
really big number that don't know they
know what's happening to the whole thing
Birch's you're like sir do you hear that
okay now that's good that tells me a lot
that confirms that I'm getting this kind
of thing and it's never gonna it's never
gonna like turn around and whip around
up and get steeper it's gonna get
shallower and shallower forever right
what's happening on me here on the left
it's like a hyperbola why is that
cuz the cube root of x right it retains
the sign I like a square 2x which gets
rid of your sign okay this is gonna be
the same thing as it's over here okay in
fact this is a function so what does
this tell you okay
negative gradient what does that mean it
means that this guy is actually gonna be
decreasing he exists and don't forget
he's approaching negative infinity going
dropping like a rock right just like the
cube root of x was right and then what's
happening over here will the exact
opposites going to be over here and by
the way you remember right this is an
odd function when you differentiate an
odd function what do you get an even
function and if you differentiate an
even function you get an odd function so
we've differentiated something which we
didn't really sorry something that we
didn't even know about but what we got
at the end was odd so therefore we must
have started with was even so once I got
this shape I've got the other shape
now now I'm not quite finished yet I
have the shape of it I do know by the
way its approaching its verdict corners
it's going to be tangent to the y-axis
what's happening an x equals zero it's
not differentiable
what differentially I have a break but
can I put in can I put in x equals zero
into this x equals 0 so y equals zero to
the power of 2/3 now you can do this any
way you like right you can either say
okay cuz this is the question we had
before which order do I do it you am i
doing the cube root of zero squared or
am i doing the cube root of zero and
then square it
right well you're gonna get it's
continuous it's continuous the function
is defined but the derivative is not
defined so it's continuous but not
differentiable